okay um do you remember the question
it's these two guys
uh one has a wage that's increasing
good morning one has a wage that's
increasing according to this um
where is it where is it actually saying
annual increase of twenty five hundred
500
um is it julian or is it the other guy
it's lawrence lawrence has an income
starts at 25k
and then it goes up in steps that are
the same every time so what kind of
sequence does that form
you go up by the same difference every
time that's an arithmetic sequence
um and then you've got julian
whose wage increases by a set percentage
right because a percentage changes in
size
based on what it's a percentage of um
you don't get an athletic sequence out
of that what do you get
did you say doctor you get it yes fine
fine i'll take that
you get a geometry progression gp for
short okay
now in particular what i want you to
have a look at i can't my cable doesn't
quite reach
i want you to look at do you have your
working in front of you have you got it
there
yeah i want you to look at your working
and the person's next to you
i first want you to look to see if your
working is substantially different
to theirs i'm not actually interested in
whether you got the right answer
or not or the same answer even it's how
you set it out
that i'm really really interested in um
for this question
doesn't matter all that much how you set
it up but as we go further into this
topic mam1
modeling financial situations um you
will find i know mrs lee has already
mentioned this to some of you
the way that you set out and communicate
your answer
to these questions um it will prove to
be decisive
if you get the right answer or not and
importantly um whether you demonstrate
your understanding okay
so let me quickly show you how my part a
is set out here's my part a
okay now the
the hardest part of it which is not very
hard at all is to work out what his
three
first years of income are there they are
you can see i've highlighted them there
in yellow
and then you kind of have to use that
fact to prove that it's an ap which we
were just talking about
right now i want you to have a look did
anyone else
i'd be very surprised if anyone did
actually but delightfully surprised
did anyone else set their answer out as
a table like i have anyone
no i wouldn't be surprised if no one did
because it kind of feels like a bit of
an overpowered tool
um to answer this question but i hope
you can see
i'm gonna make the argument that it's a
very clear way of setting out what's
going on yeah
you've got your three different years
you've got the increase every time and
then you've got the result
over here on the right hand side okay
and then you draw a conclusion
you're like every time there's a common
difference it's an ap fine let's look at
part b
here you can start to see a little bit
more of the advantage that you get in
setting this out
in a table because you're just having
equations flying everywhere
some of you actually ran into this
problem where you were like wait what is
his wage
you'd see that 15 and that's the
increase but that's not his wage that's
how much his wage increases by
right so you can see unlike uh with
lawrence the increase column here is
actually a little more
interesting and useful it changes every
time it changes on the basis of whatever
the previous year's
income was and then you get your
resulting things over here
now it's very important that you do show
i'll highlight it right down here
um you do show this result that proves
that it's a gp
right you've got your division for from
one turn to the next one and you have to
do it
for all of them right so it's not a
common difference it's a common ratio
right
and you get 1.15 not 0.15 because
otherwise it will be increasing from
year to year okay now
just quickly because it's going to be
relevant to our topic today the 1
and the 0.15 they each represent two
different things
right what's the 0.15 again
it's the percentage it's 15 it's how
much it increases by
why is there a one there why is it not
0.15
yeah it has to include whatever the
initial salary was or maybe not initial
it's
just the previous years because you keep
on doing it over and over again so
there's the one and then there's the
0.15
okay now lastly and this is where the
table becomes most
useful um maybe we're snapping a picture
of this because i don't expect you to
write it on it's quite a lot of working
as you can see okay
i hope you've got those numbers they
should match right
but importantly you can see and you're
going to get asked to do this all the
time right you're comparing
two different sequences here two
different progressions
and it can be really easy just to model
up all the numbers now some of you
will have just gone for this second pair
of numbers you look at year number six
you show that um at that point julian's
wage is more than lawrence's and you
just say
i'm done can anyone tell me why that's
not enough
you have to do the previous users as
well
have a think you can if you've got the
question there it might help because the
language of the question is very
important yeah good i'll clarify and
then i'll let parent have a go
my question is actually i'm just asked
how many of you just did year six just
calculated year six
and left off year five it's fairly
common most people would sort of like
that's the instinct
okay that's fine all right now i'm
suggesting it's not enough that's only
half the answer if you only do one year
and not the other
okay that's right do you know how you do
um one point one five to the power six
times one isn't that year five
because you're counting for five years
not six
have a think for a second let's just
let's just think about what sorry said
because it made me for a second question
what's going on
yeah okay
okay have a look have a think for a
second let me just make sure i
understand what you're saying strang and
then let's see if
other people can throw a thought to this
um so you're looking at my year six
calculation here right
and you can see i'll zoom in what have i
used by the way
i've actually used the formula in that
first line i just haven't given the
statement i've just put numbers in ar to
the
n minus one right that's the formula for
the nth term of uh gp
yep um but then six minus one
is going to give you five is that is
that isn't that the fifth year why is
this the sixth year molly what's your
thought if you put
six it would have been six after the
first which would have been seven
so the reason you remove one is that so
you have five after the first one
[Music]
okay now if you didn't quite catch that
if you didn't quite catch that
think about how a gp forms right what do
we call
yeah you get it what's the premium we
use for the first term in a gp
a right so we start with a there's your
first term and then you look at the next
one what's the next one
it's a gp right it's going to be a
times whatever your common ratio is
right ar
is that okay and then you go ah squared
and so on right now if i'm going to the
sixth year here's the first here's the
second here's the third
here's the fourth he is the fifth
here is the sixth year but the index is
five does that make sense
if you wanna think about it this way in
terms of this particular question his
income has increased five times it
started there and it's increased once
twice three
four five times so that's why the index
ended up being five make sense
okay all right now i did ask the
question and we didn't quite answer it
apparently i wonder if you want to
suggest why do we have to work out
actually two years ago
that it doesn't actually increase in the
fifth year but it's in the 16th
yeah fantastic the question has this one
word there which is
the reason why we have to do this it
says show that the 60 is the
first time right because otherwise i
could have gone to like the tenth year
in the 10th year obviously this guy's
earning more but that doesn't show that
the 10th year is the first time it
happens
the sixth year is the first time it
happens you've got to show before that
and there's a change and that's why you
can see i've highlighted in different
colors
again to try and communicate as clearly
as possible okay